for many decades the UN has helped
deliver stability and Security in much
of the world
it's provided a place for Nations to
work together on shared challenges
and it has promoted the principles of
sovereignty and self-determination even
through the Cold War and if it's after
moth
but today those principles that have
defined Our Lives since the dark days of
the 1940s of fracturing
for the first time in the history of
this assembly we are meeting during a
large-scale war of aggression in Europe
and authoritarian states are undermining
stability and security around the world
geopolitics is entering a new era
one that requires those who believe in
the founding principles of the United
Nations to stand up and be counted
in the United Kingdom we are entering a
new era too
I join you here just two days after her
late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II was laid
to rest
we deeply mourn her passing and we pay
tribute to her service
she was the rock on which modern Britain
was built
he symbolized the post-war values on
which this organization was founded
our constitutional monarchy underpinned
by a Democratic Society has delivered
stability and progress
her late Majesty transcended difference
and healed division
we saw this in her visits to post
apartheid South Africa and to the
Republic of Ireland
when she addressed this General Assembly
65 years ago
she warned that it was vital not only to
have strong ideals but also to have the
political will to deliver on them
now we must show that will
we must fight to defend those ideals and
we must deliver on them for all of our
people
as we say farewell to our late Queen
the UK opens a new chapter
a new Caroline age
under his majesty King Charles II
we want this era to be one of Hope and
progress
one in which we defend the values of
individual liberty
self-determination and equality before
the law
one in which we ensure that freedom and
democracy Prevail for all people
and one in which we deliver on the
commitments that her late Majesty the
queen made here 65 years ago
this is about what we do in the United
Kingdom and what we do as member states
of the United Nations
so today I will set out what we steps we
are taking at home in the UK
and our proposed blueprint for the new
era we're now in the new Partnerships
and the new instruments that we need to
collectively adopt
our commitment to Hope and progress must
begin at home
in the lives of each of of every citizen
that we serve
our strength as a nation comes from the
strong foundations of freedom and
democracy
democracy gives people the right to
choose their own path
and it evolves to reflect the
aspirations of citizens
it unleashes Enterprise ideas and
opportunity
and it protects the freedoms that are at
the very core of our Humanity
by contrast autocracies say the seeds of
their own demise by suppressing their
citizens
they are fundamentally rigid and unable
to adapt
any short-term gains are eroded in the
long term because these societies stifle
the aspiration and creativity that are
vital to long-term growth
a country where artificial intelligence
acts as judge and jury
where there are no human rights and no
fundamental freedoms is not the kind of
place anybody truly wants to live
and it's not the kind of world that we
want to build
but we cannot simply assume that there
will be a democratic future
there is a real struggle going on
between different forms of society
between democracies and autocracies
and unless Democratic societies deliver
on the economy and the security that our
citizens expect we will fall behind
we need to keep improving and renewing
what we're doing for this new era
demonstrating that democracy delivers
as prime minister of the United Kingdom
I'm determined that we will deliver the
progress that people expect
I will lead a New Britain for a new era
firstly this begins with growth and
building a British economy that rewards
Enterprise and attracts investment
our long-term aim is to get our economy
growing it's an average of 2.5 percent
we need this growth to deliver
investment around our country to deliver
the jobs and high wages people expect
and deliver Public Services like the
National Health Service
we want people to keep more of the money
they earn so they can have more control
of their own lives and contribute to the
Future
secondly it means securing affordable
and reliable supplies of energy
we are cutting off the toxic power and
pipelines from authoritarian regimes and
strengthening our energy resilience
we will ensure that we can't be coerced
or harmed by The Reckless actions of
Rogue actors abroad
and we will transition to a future based
on renewable and nuclear energy while
ensuring the gas used during that
transition is from reliable sources
including our own North Sea production
we will be a net energy exporter by
2040.
thirdly we're safeguarding the security
of our economy the supply chains the
critical minerals the food the
technology that drive growth and protect
the lives and health of people
we won't be strategically dependent on
those who seek to weaponize the global
economy instead we're reforming our
economy to get Britain moving and we
want to work with our allies so we can
all move forward together
the Free World needs this economic
strength and resilience to push back
against authoritarian aggression and win
this new era of strategic competition
we must do this together
so we are building new Partnerships
around the world
we're fortifying our deep security
alliances in Europe and Beyond through
NATO and the joint expeditionary Force
we're deepening our links with fellow
democracies like India Israel Indonesia
and South Africa
we're building new security ties with
friends in the indo-pacific and the Gulf
we've shown leadership on free and fair
trade striking trade agreements with
Australia New Zealand and Japan and many
others are in the process of exceeding
to the trans-pacific partnership
rather than exerting influence through
debt aggression and taking control of
critical infrastructure and minerals we
are building strategic ties based on
Mutual benefit and Trust
and we're deepening Partnerships like
the G7 and the Commonwealth
we must also collectively extend the
hand of friendship to those parts of the
world that have too often been left
behind and left vulnerable to Global
challenges
whether it's the Pacific or Caribbean
island States dealing with the impact of
climate change or the Western Balkans
dealing with persistent threats to their
stability
the UK is providing funding using the
might of the city of London and our
security capabilities to provide better
Alternatives than those offered by
malign regimes
the Resolute International response to
Ukraine has shown how we can deliver
decisive Collective action
the response has been built on
Partnerships and alliances
and also on being prepared to use new
instruments unprecedented sanctions
diplomatic action and Rapid Military
Support
there's been a strength of collective
purpose we've met many times spoken many
times on the phone and we've made things
happen
now we must use these instruments in a
more systematic way to push back on the
economic aggression of authoritarian
regimes
the G7 on our like-minded partners
should act as an economic NATO
collectively defending our prosperity
if the economy of a partner is being
targeted by an aggressive regime we
should act to support them
all for one and one for all
through the g7s 600 billion dollar
partnership for Global infrastructure
and investment we are providing an
honest reliable alternative around the
world free from the debt with strings
attached
and we have to go further to French or
our supply chains and end strategic
dependence
this is how we will build collective
security strengthen our resilience and
Safeguard freedom and democracy
but we cannot let up on dealing with the
crisis we face today
no one is threatening Russia
yet as we meet here this evening in
Ukraine Barbara's weapons are being used
to kill and maim people
rape is being used as an instrument of
War
families are being torn apart
and this morning we have seen Putin
trying to justify his catastrophic
failures
he's doubling down by sending even more
reservists to a terrible fate
he's desperately trying to claim the
mantle of democracy for a regime without
human rights or freedoms and he's making
yet more bogus claims and saber-rattling
threats
this will not work
the International Alliance is strong
and Ukraine is strong
the contrast between Russia's conduct
and Ukraine's Brave dignified first lady
Elena zelenska who's here at the UN
today could not be more Stark
the ukrainians aren't just defending
their own country
they're defending our values and the
security of the whole world
that's why we must act
that's why the UK will set will spend
three percent of GDP on defense by 2030
maintaining our position as the leading
security actor in Europe
and that's why at this crucial moment in
the conflict I pledge that we will
sustain or increase our military support
to Ukraine for as long as it takes
UK new UK weapons are arriving in
Ukraine as I speak including more mrls
Rockets
we will not rest until Ukraine prevails
in all of these areas on all of the
fronts the time to act is now
this is a decisive moment in our history
in the history of this organization and
in the history of freedom
the story of 2022 could have been that
of an authoritarian State rolling its
tanks over the border of peaceful
neighbor and subjugating its people
instead it's a story of freedom fighting
back
in the face of rising aggression we've
shown that we have the power to act and
the resolve to see it through
but this can't be a one-off
this must be a new era where we commit
to ourselves to our citizens and this
institution that we will do whatever it
takes whatever it takes to deliver for
our people and defend our values
as we mourn our late Queen and remember
her call to this assembly we must devote
ourselves to this task
Britain's commitment to this is total
we will be a dynamic reliable and
trustworthy partner
together with our friends and allies
around the world we will continue to
Champion Freedom sovereignty and
democracy
and together we can Define this new era
as one of Hope and progress thank you